it's not an easy job to be a truth
teller and as a matter of fact in the
last five weeks I think my hair has
accelerated it's a gray my name is Mary
Willingham and I work at the University
of North Carolina Chapel Hill
when I started working at the University
I worked in the academic support program
for student athletes and I saw pretty
quickly that athletes were not getting
the same access to a real education like
all the other students they're writing
levels were so low I'm talking second or
third grade maybe we really needed to
work on letters and sounds sometimes
they told me that they had never written
a paragraph before
for many many years close to two decades
we had a paper class system where
athletes wouldn't ever have to go to
class they would just at some point
during the semester be given a prompt to
write a paper and nine times out of ten
they didn't really write the paper it
was just a recycled paper and the papers
were almost always created as a or V but
every day I ask myself if learning took
place so that's how I reconciled all of
this fraud was that I was still doing
something to help them move along at
least a little
I even stopped going to the athletic
events because it just it just didn't
seem right to me anymore my title was
taken from me and I was moved to the
basement and you know all the typical
things that happen to whistleblowers
kind of classic and I really believed
that the university would do the right
thing and fix the problem now that was
out in the open
we're still not doing the right thing
for these guys who am i teaching any
remedial classes on this campus because
we say that we don't need them but we do
need them we can't teach students up at
this level when they're down at this
level it doesn't work if we're going to
connect college sport to academies of
higher up learning then we need to make
sure that these students are getting the
real education that we're promising them
I think game days are spectacular and
something that is part of our culture
here in this country and so somehow
we've got to figure out the way to do
the right thing and still be able to
have the entertainment that we enjoy on
Saturday
you